the planet is infected with us we're all
gonna die uh isn't that all true and and
correct it's certainly not true and it's
uh and and actually the history of the
relationship between population growth
and uh abundance of Natural Resources is
much more complex than people realize
it's very interesting to see how extreme
environmentalism maps onto Christian
theology uh on the one hand you've got
your Garden of Eden that's the world
before industrialization you have your
Devils fossil fuel fossil fuel CEOs
people like that you have your Saints
greater Thornburg you have your
priesthood which is the ipcc scientists
and of course you even have indulgences
like back in the in the days before
Reformation where you are allowed to fly
around the world on a private jet but so
long as you give a few thousand pounds
or dollars to a green cause all those
sins are simply washed away and one of
the fundamental features of any religion
any religion is apocalypse
is the end of days what we are saying is
that if the world is going to end it
will certainly not end because we are
going to run out of Natural Resources
the British energy problems are not an
outcome of physical limits on fossil
fuels or energy that can be produced in
the world they are an outcome of stupid
decisions made by your politicians for
the last 20 years
nothing
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a brilliant
guest today is the editor of
humanprogress.org a senior fellow at the
center for Global liberty and prosperity
whose latest book is called super
abundance the story of population growth
Innovation and human flourishing on an
infinitely Bountiful Planet very loaded
uh Mariam to be welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much for having me it's a
great pleasure uh it's great to have you
on before we talk about your book and
your very interesting views on the world
uh tell everybody who are you how are
you where you are what brings you to be
sitting here talking to us
um well I guess uh it starts with my
birth in czechoslovak socialist republic
um and um
that's uh that's really my background
then uh when I was a child my parents
moved to South Africa uh later I went to
Great Britain I studied at Saint Andrews
University and I've been um in
Washington DC at the Cato Institute
which is a Libertarian think tank for
the last 20 years and as you mentioned I
ran a website called viewingprogress.org
which is basically just a website trying
to document and promote the notion that
the world is improving along many
different dimensions of human well-being
and that led me to writing a book about
population and Innovation and natural
resources
well speaking of all of that uh Myron
the the self-evident truth that
everyone's been completely persuaded
about for the last God knows how many
years is the planets overpopulated
humans are the virus uh the planet is
infected with us uh we're all gonna die
and as we die we're gonna make
everything terrible uh isn't that all
true and and correct
it's certainly not true and it's uh and
and actually the history of the
relationship between population growth
and uh abundance of Natural Resources is
much more complex than people realize in
our dumbed down age uh for two and a
half thousand years people have been
wondering what is the exact relationship
between population growth and resources
and people have been genuinely torn on
the issue not all of them were negative
ancient Greeks and ancient Chinese
understood that you know if you had too
many people in marginal land at some
point you could have famines and people
would die off that's true and that
happened often on the other hand uh
Nations needed more people for the
military and to pay taxes so there was
always this sort of uneasy relationship
between the two Notions I think where
the the notion of overpopulation really
became very toxic and very negativistic
was with uh with was in England actually
in 1798 when Thomas Malthus who was an
English Anglican prelate published a
population an essay on population where
he basically
showed what he thought he was showing
mathematically that whereas population
all grows at a geometrical rate which is
to say 1 2 4 16
Etc
food would only grow at an arithmetic
rate one two three four five and
therefore that sort of gave a scientific
imprimatur to this notion that too many
people would lead to a catastrophe and
that was picked up by the famous uh
Stanford University biologist Paul
Ehrlich in his population bomb in 1968
and
um you know people have been debating it
ever since now I I should perhaps say
um in in that there has been amongst
intellectuals and academics a slight
shift away from this sort of
overpopulation over consumption of
resources
Dooms tourism
um but but that has not penetrated the
public Consciousness so to this day you
can find the United Nations publishing
press releases saying that growth in
population is going to create a worse
World there is a another website run by
an NGO called overshoot day where they
try to measure how many planets we would
need in order to feed Humanity
if it keeps growing we have the the
growth agenda we have the anti-natalist
agenda we have newspaper stories about
how the world would be much better off
without any human beings in it and on
the absolute far extreme we have people
who have decided to take this issue into
their own hands some of the mass
Shooters in the United States and also
in Norway in recent decade have been
driven by malthusian concerns we had a
horrific Mass killing in the United
States about four years ago where a man
killed 22 people in in El Paso and left
behind him a Manifesto saying basically
you guys are using too many resources
you won't stop therefore I have to do
something about it by killing as many of
you as I can so the issue is very much
still at the back of the public
Consciousness and this book is meant to
somehow combat it
and Marion why is it that so many people
think that overpopulation is a real
danger for our planet and the future of
the human race
I think it's because the notion of
finitude of atoms which is absolutely
true the the world really here it has
only a finitude of atoms is actually
quite
um
it is quite common sensical and
intuitive which is to say if you have
the finite quantity of atoms but you are
increasing the people using those atoms
then at some point you must run out
but this ignores a very fundamental
difference between human beings and
other animals we are animals but we are
animals who are capable of planning
forward and we are capables and we are
animals capable of innovating out of our
problems and that is done through human
knowledge so American Economist Thomas
solo
has a famous quote where he says that
these the caveman had exactly the same
amount of resources the same amount of
atoms at his disposal as we do today but
the difference between his stand up
living in our standard living is the
knowledge we are able to bring into the
world and use those atoms in a in a more
uh in a more intelligent way a perfect
example of this would be the difference
between a Rolls-Royce driven out of a
car dealership worth half a million
pounds and then when you smash it into
the wall
um you know the number of atoms are
exactly equal
uh but the value in the new Rolls-Royce
and the destroyed Rolls-Royce is
obviously very different because the
atoms have been rearranged differently
one in a very intelligent way and the
other one in a chaotic way so
with the finite number of atoms we can
still create an infinite amount of value
that's what we are basically saying
another example if I may
um is iPhone
iPhone is a great way of
dematerializing uh our the world in
other words we are saving a lot of atoms
that we don't have to put into
television sets into cameras into Maps
into campuses into calculators and all
those other things that we would have to
have instead we put it on this device
so that that's that I think should um I
I hope it goes some way into explaining
why the number of atoms in the world is
actually not a limiting factor in terms
of how much of value we can create
um do you think part of The Narrative of
overpopulation comes from the fact that
a lot of people who would believe this
live in cities now if you live in
central London and you experience
Central London every day of the week and
you're trying to find a property in
central London and you're trying to get
to the tube and it would feel all the
time like you were living in a constant
state of overpopulation
it's possible but there are other parts
of the world where people don't
necessarily feel gloomy about the future
because there are too many people living
on top of each other
um China the Chinese at least until
recently had a very positive attitude
about the future even though you know
they lived on top of each other in a few
very important and very popular cities
Hong Kong is an example of a of a
territory which has a very high level of
population density and yet it was a very
vibrant place where people apparently
were very happy because they kept on
moving there
um I think that if we are looking at the
source of discomfort and a sense of
dejection about the future it may come
from the fact that uh in in Britain you
cannot build that many houses or rather
not that you cannot build that many
houses but you refuse to build that many
houses of governmental policy and by the
way I'm not bashing Britain I've spent
five years in your beautiful country and
I love it if we have the same problem in
the United States it's not that all of
these people living in the cities
um you know are concerned about
overpopulation is just that they they've
decided that
you're not going to build in my backyard
I like my little house you know
um and um and I don't want uh I I don't
want to be I don't want you to to build
anymore that that is a concern
um but I think it's policy driven rather
than driven by some sort of a uh
fundamental physical lack of space I
mean if you wanted to you could build a
brand new city in the United Kingdom
full of uh skyscrapers and um you know
create half a million housing units that
way but you've made a decision not to
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
reg wallets have an incredible solution
for you this is mine Sleek stylish and
with an industrial look to it can fit 12
cards with cash on the back using a clip
like this one or a strap we've got one
for the whole team I've got one Francis
has one even our producer Anton has one
but he's from Liverpool so he flogged
his on the black market the great thing
about Ridge is that they give you a
lifetime guarantee which means if you
want you can have only one wallet for
the rest of your life Rich are so
confident in the quality of their
product they will give you 45 days to
test drive their wallet that means you
can get the wallet use it and if you
don't like it you can return it within
45 days because Ridge is such great guys
they're going to of you ten percent off
and free worldwide shipping and returns
to take advantage of this incredible
offer go to ridge.com forward slash
trigger that's ridge.com forward slash
trigger and use our special code which
is of course trigger
uh Marin uh before I I want to hear from
you because in the book you talk about
the figures around all of this and and
the fact that actually every new human
being on average produces more resources
than they take up and you explain why
this is and I want to get into all of
that but I want to talk a little bit
about the cultural and philosophical
underpinnings of all of this because I
hear you the malthusian view begins to
take over and blah blah blah but there's
there's got to be a reason this I feel
like there's got to be also a cultural
and a philosophical explanation of why
so many people uh uh find appealing some
of these things that we now hear we've
got 12 harvests left the world's about
to end we've got a climate crisis we've
got a population bomb we've got to this
we've got to that why are so many people
and I by the way don't even exclude
myself because until I started looking
at the data and talking to people like
you and Peter zahan and a bunch of
others I was very persuaded by
instinctively persuaded without looking
at the data by some of these arguments
so what is it about our culture in this
moment and in recent history that makes
us so susceptible to this idea that we
are a plague on the planet
s to do with the decline of traditional
religion I personally am not religious
but I do buy into
GK chesterton's famous quote where he
said that when people stop believing in
God they don't believe in nothing they
believe in anything and I think that
human beings have this
fundamental need for the transcendental
right so we are the only species in the
world who are capable of
foreseeing our death
um you know an antelope running through
the the African bush
um she or he understand that
you know that they could be eaten by a
line they're running away to save their
lives but they don't have a sense of
finitude of their lives they don't
realize that you know they will they
will grow old and die they don't they
don't have a need for the transcendental
but human beings do
uh they need to get some sort of a
meaning out of their lives now in the
old days uh obviously religion be it be
Judaism or Christianity or
um
or Islam uh provided that kind of that
kind of certainty uh but without it
people still need a a search for the
transcendental they still need to commit
their lives to a meaning to some sort of
a heroic vision of themselves what is it
that they are trying to accomplish with
their lives aside from going to work
and I think that many people especially
in secular societies have embraced
Extreme environmentalism as a substitute
for religion
um it's very interesting to see how
extreme environmentalism maps onto
Christian theology uh on the one hand
you've got your Garden of Eden that's
the world before industrialization you
have your Devils
fossil fuel fossil fuel CEOs people like
that you have your Saints Greta thumberg
you have your priesthood which is the
ipcc scientists and of course you even
have indulgences like back in the in the
days before Reformation where you are
allowed as one of the chosen uh few to
to fly around the world on a private jet
but so long as you give a few thousand
pounds or dollars to a green cause all
those sins are simply washed away that
is why somebody like Leo DiCaprio or
John Kerry
um or Emma Thompson can go on the Telly
having just flown in the first class and
be good environmentalists their sins
have been washed away by saying the
right incantations and saying the right
amount of money to these green causes so
that's a very long way of saying that I
think that there are religious overtones
to environmentalism and one of the
fundamental features of any religion any
religion is apocalypse is the end of
days the world that ends and is going to
reconstitute itself in some way
and uh Christianity has its um Islam has
it Judaism has it Hinduism Buddhism have
it
um some religions like Christianity are
working up to the end of days where the
world will end others have a circular uh
or cyclical
um uh religious belief where the world
will be destroyed but then it's going to
be renewed and it's an eternal cycle
like that but all of them have this
notion of a of an apocalypse and so I I
think that that plays a very large role
in why people keep on embracing these
apocalyptic views one of the one of the
statistics I'm very proud uh in the book
that we have found is that
the number of apocalyptic movies uh has
been growing every decade since the
1950s even though the world has improved
along very many different dimensions we
live longer we live healthier lives we
are much richer poverty is collapsing
around the world but with every decade
the number of apocalyptic movies is
actually increasing with one exception
and it was 1990s because of the peaceful
resolution of the Cold War right
that makes so much sense and really
really profound points Marin I love it
so
convert me make me an anti-apocalyptic
pro-human
pro-human expansion person what what are
the facts what is the data what should
people know
well it's not in the book we don't argue
that apocalypse cannot happen uh this is
not a book which predicts the future
there are plenty of ways in which
Humanity could destroy itself we have
plenty of nuclear weapons we have a
Madman in Europe uh currently
threatening to use them that's just one
way in which uh apocalypse could be
brought about we could have another
asteroid strike we could have a pathogen
that we don't really know how to cure by
the way one way in which having a bigger
economy and a richer economy and
continue to grow economically is that
the Richer the society is the more
likely we are going to be able to come
up with solutions to Future problems a
society 50 years from now which has
unlimited amount of energy created by
fusion power for example could
potentially power an extra strong laser
that would destroy an asteroid we cannot
do it right now because we are our
knowledge is too primitive and our
society is not rich enough or
if we are extremely wealthy in the
future you know
we could be six times richer on average
across the globe by the year 2100 if
that happens then of course the society
will have much more money to do things
like we have just done which is to shut
down the society for two years to wait
out a covet pandemic uh part of the
reason why your current economic reforms
are so difficult to push through is
because you've just burned through half
a bill half a trillion pounds here in
this country we spend something like
four trillion dollars uh to get through
the pandemic and but but let's imagine
the society is extremely rich well that
would allow us to shut down the economy
if we needed to for for a few months
while we are looking for a vaccine for a
new pathogen which you know is coming
because on a molecular level Evolution
continues to go on and and pathogens are
continuing to evolve to get around our
defense systems so there's a lot of ways
in which the world could come to an end
and we are not dismissing all those
possibilities what we are saying is that
if the world is going to end it will
certainly not end because we are going
to run out of Natural Resources that's
what we are saying we are we are trying
to remove just one of the breaks in the
wall of the apocalyptic thinking saying
to the extent that you are worried about
natural resources you don't have to be
because we have plenty we are going to
have plenty
um if there if there is a resource which
is going to go up in price because it
becomes less less abundant and more
scarce then we are going then a lot of
things are going to happen one thing
that's going to happen is that we are
going to use less of it we are going to
create efficiency gains
this kind of water
used to weigh three pounds of aluminum
now it it weighs sorry three pounds
three ounces of aluminum now it weighs
um half an ounce uh we of course uh
replace things which become expensive uh
with other things we no longer kill
whales in order to produce candles we
use electricity
um when prices go up we search for new
deposits so there are many ways in which
Humanity get around the problem of uh of
of Natural Resources becoming more
expensive in a short run in the long run
however they are becoming much less
expensive so if you want we can get into
the data
yeah Marion this is all incredibly
interesting and oh just a refreshing
change from the narratives that we've
been so sort of forced to swallow
how much of a problem will depopulation
be
because you touch upon it in in your
book particularly when it comes to China
and the Chinese economy
depopulation is going to be problematic
along many different dimensions
one is that Western Advanced countries
social democracies by and large and I
include here the United States which has
a bigger social uh safety net than
Canada
we have promised so much to Future
Generations that we have no idea how we
are going to pay for our social security
is the Ponzi scheme based on the notion
that there are always more people at the
bottom paying the retirees at the top
if that pyramid now starts going like
this
then of course our taxes will go to will
have to go massively up in order to pay
for the promises that we have promised
to Future Generations in terms of Social
Security another problem with the
population is going to be national debt
if you have few people being taxed then
it's going to be so much harder and so
much longer to pay down debt but the
most important reason why
um
why the population could be a problem
not could be but will be a problem uh is
that human beings are the only entities
in the world capable of having new ideas
and new ideas
lead to inventions and those inventions
then get Market tested and out of that
you get Innovations which improve
productivity and standards of living
so without human beings no new ideas no
new cancer drugs no better ways of
Transport no new breakthroughs in energy
including clean energy we simply need
people in order to uh in order to
innovate nobody else is going to do it
for us unless we get AI and that and I
have no idea if or when that is going to
happen
Marion and how big a problem is the
Chinese situation for China but also for
the world as a whole because it's one of
the biggest economies that there is and
it's a manufacturing Powerhouse
so I cannot quantify it what I can tell
you is that China would have had 400
million additional people today but it's
if you didn't have the crazy one child
policy between I don't know 1978 and
2015 but much more importantly it's it's
population pyramid would look much
healthier than it is today
I'm not necessarily worried about
Chinese
um
about Chinese
industrial power because of course we
can move uh production to countries like
Bangladesh and India and many other
places in some ways it might be even
preferable because there are democracies
um you know and our relationships with
them that is to say British and American
relationships with them will be better
in the future then then they are likely
to be in China if she remains in power
so I'm not terribly worried about that I
I am worried that um
because of this insane population policy
China
is reaching a peak
um which is to say I don't believe that
China is ever going to uh going to
catching up with Western democracies GDP
per capita in the United States is
something like seventy thousand dollars
in China is ten thousand dollars it's
very difficult to see China becoming
seven seven times richer
um in a situation where where they're
going to where they are turning more
dictatorial both politically but also
economically without economic freedom
political Freedom you cannot have
economic growth uh because it's not just
population growth but those people also
have to be free right
um China has been the the largest or the
most populated country for at least 2
000 years but there were dirt poor until
recently
um because you need people but those
people must be free to talk to each
other to write to publish to associate
to exchange ideas and to criticize each
other's ideas and if China is not going
to have freedom of speech it cannot
innovate similarly if it's not going to
have high level of economic freedom then
people are not going to be allowed to
sell to buy to invest to profit and she
has been moving away from economic
freedom for at least 10 years so that
tells me that China could be reaching a
peak and that in itself has potentially
negative consequences because if China
believes or the Chinese leadership
believes that they're never going to get
stronger than they currently are this
may be their time to attack Taiwan and
bring the world into a conflict
it's really I'm really enjoying this
conversation so much you're making some
brilliant points
um and one of the things that you you
touched on is something I talked about
in my book but it seems to me you have a
much more in-depth understanding of the
connection between freedom and
prosperity and I think this is something
that people seem to have forgotten for a
while and maybe that is because uh we
endlessly hear about how successful
China has been in in recent decades and
so on but you touched on it but explain
to people why is freedom necessary for
prosperity for technological progress
for scientific progress
well China has mimicked a lot of Western
development and I'm glad for it by the
way I really am delighted that 1.3
billion people or how many they are we
cannot trust the Chinese statistics are
much better off than they used to be at
the time of now when he killed 45
million of his fellow citizens and and
Chinese people had to eat dirt in order
to survive so I'm really delighted about
that but
um but but what China cannot do very
easily in fact I don't think that it
can't do it at all is to produce new
um Cutting Edge
research because for that you need
Freedom
um why are our
covet vaccines so much better than they
are in China is because we are able to
rely on on on much better technology we
are able to critique each other we have
open sourced
um we we have we have we have data which
we have to subject to uh criticism from
fellow scientists you know and uh people
if they don't like something they don't
have to take it right you cannot force
somebody to to take the vaccine and so
whereas in China they have developed an
inferior product which they are forcing
their people to use and that has then no
con consequences such as having to shut
down entire cities and therefore destroy
your economy
the relationship between
freedom and intellectual progress is
very interesting and it has roots in
deep history and if you'll allow me I'll
I'll I'll I'll talk a little bit about
the the difference between uh between
the Chinese Empire and Europe
so
Empires generally are so large that they
are not worried about being attacked
from the outside China is not worried
about being attacked from the outside
China's biggest concern is domestic
tranquility
and the greatest danger to domestic
tranquility is to have free people who
are swapping ideas criticizing the
government and so forth so Chinese
government for Millennia the same goes
for the Ottoman Empire for the Russian
Empire and many other Empires that have
come and gone
their biggest concern was to clamp down
on
domestic descent again they are not
worried about outside they are worried
about problems inside and so they squash
any kind of innovativeness
Europe was different and it is for that
reason in my humble opinion why
Industrial Revolution and the
enlightenment starts in Europe and which
is to say that whereas the Europeans had
Empires on the outside they conquered
other peoples Europe was never conquered
after the fall of the Roman Empire
Charles V tried to do it in the 16th
century Louis XVI tried to do it in 17th
century Napoleon did it but then lost it
and he never conquered Britain but the
point is that Europe was always
dismembered Europe was always disjointed
and so there was a lot of competition
going on between different countries in
Europe in Europe
what these small countries worried about
was not internal descent it was that
they are going to be swallowed up by
competing countries uh and as a
consequence they had to allow for a
greater degree of domestic freedom and
they had to attract the best brains
because that allowed them to innovate
both militarily but also financially and
economically
there the European way of succeeding and
of of preserve of self-preservation was
basically to generate economic uh growth
at home
and that is it is through this
competition and and a desire for
self-preservation
that um that that liberalism with small
L Classical liberalism arose in Europe
in the 18th century
Marion it's it's
what you're speaking about because right
the way through there's this vein of
optimism and I find it incredibly
jarring because I'm a rabid pessimist
because and looking at the world now
it seems as if resources are going to be
more scarce than ever we have an energy
crisis we have the war in Ukraine we
have that and how that's going to impact
and how it's going to cause a food
crisis
is there room for optimism amongst all
of this
no
with all of this situation as we see it
at the moment
the British energy problems are not an
outcome of physical limits on fossil
fuels or energy that can be produced in
the world they are an outcome of stupid
decisions made by your politicians for
the last 20 years
and maybe even longer in Europe on the
continent it's the same thing it's not
an outcome of it's not a outcome of
climate change it's an outcome of
climate policies we moved too quickly
without having a plan
to basically
eliminate as much as possible of fossil
fuels whatever your view on fossil fuels
I'm not taking a position on this uh I I
do believe that emitting ever more CO2
in the atmosphere is a problem but
clearly the timeline and the plan that
our politicians have come up with was
completely unrealistic we are not paying
a price for there being too little oil
or gas in the world or or uranium
we are paying a penalty for politicians
forcing us into energy consumption
patterns which were not congruent with
reality
and that's what the book is about the
book tells you that there is plenty to
be used for hundreds of thousands
millions of years we are never going to
run out of these uh out of these uh out
of these um
energy sources or natural resources but
yes as a society could we we could
certainly decide not to use them and
simply to shut off the lights and just
um you know close the door on Western
Civilization that we could do that but
that's going to be a choice it's not
going to be forced uh forced on us by
physical limits of the planet that's
what the book is about Maron but what do
you mean I remember when I was at school
you know I mean all this stuff should
have run out by now coal was going to
run out by 2050 oil was going to run out
by 2020 I think the other stuff was
going to run out even earlier uh we were
never going to run out of oil we're
never going to run out of coal we're
never going to run out of those
resources
in a word no today we have greater known
resources of oil than we had 100 years
ago even though we obviously used a lot
of oil in the intervening 100 years we
also have more known reserves of natural
gas and these are known reserves they do
not mean that those are the only
reserves in the world
they are the known reserves given the
price of oil and gas today in other
words it pays us
to go and explore parts of the world to
look for additional deposits at this
price if the price was twice as high we
would have twice as much of an incentive
to go and explore other
um other parts of the world in in search
for new deposits
um so those are just that's just what we
know but also don't forget
that just because we are using some sort
of an energy today that doesn't mean
that we are going to be using that
energy or natural resource 100 or 200
years from now a perfect example of that
would be the recent
craze and recent concern around the
world about lithium and lithium prices
so at the moment the commercially viable
technology that we have
in order to produce
in order to produce electric batteries
for our electric vehicles is Lithium-ion
batteries and they are very good
and obviously the you can open a
newspaper on any given day and there is
going to be probably a story there that
is like a high likelihood there is going
to be a story about you know where are
the lithium deposits how are we going to
get to them what if the Chinese get
there first well who is to say that we
are going to be using lithium ion in 10
years or 20 years in order to Power
electric vehicles there are scientists
who are already working on sodium ion
batteries which is just salt
and who knows what is going to be
happening in the future so I think that
people who are concerned about us
running out of anything they forget that
technology is dynamic technology always
changes and uh just because we are using
something today doesn't mean it will
need it in the future
and what why is it Marion that certain
types of energy uh
for instance nuclear is seen as even
though it's it's cleaner than the vast
majority of others at our disposal
we are less reluctant to use it more
reluctant well sorry more reluctant to
use it my apologies absolutely why is
that
gosh um
so having spoken to people who have been
thinking and looking around this since
the 1970s
it seemed to have been an outcome of the
world being greatly concerned about
nuclear weapons that at some point that
sort of concern about nuclear weapons in
the 60s has sort of
um sort of flown over into concern about
having nuclear energy at all
in the United States we had a seven
miles Island Seven Mile Island nuclear
accident in the 1970s nobody died but of
course Americans like they always do
overreacted and we stopped building
nuclear power stations ever since
um I believe that the agency responsible
for nuclear safety uh and permit program
for American nuclear uh Power Station
Endeavor in its 50-year existence has
never given a single permit for a single
nuclear reactor in the United States so
we haven't built anything in a very very
long time
um the other thing is of course that the
media simply refuses to report on one
basic fact is that when you look at
people dying from different sources of
energy nuclear is one of the safest
not only is nuclear good because it
doesn't produce any CO2 into the
atmosphere which is what I thought the
environmentalists were concerned about
but it doesn't kill that many people in
the in the in the nuclear power creation
process very few people die on
on site building these nuclear reactors
for example in industrial accidents uh
compared to even building of of wind
farms you know or hydroelectric dams the
people always die in building of these
things and nuclear is actually pretty
pretty safe and of course it beats the
hell out of uh millions of people who
die due to indoor pollution or burning
of
biofuels and things like that and so
it's a it's a choice that people have
made the extreme environmentalist
movement and I want to distinguish very
deliberately and and as clearly as I can
between smart environmentalists who get
this
and the extreme environmentalists who
don't there has been recently a shift
away
from this
um you know blanket refusal to
consider nuclear power
um and the people are looking at it
again and I hope that we will be seeing
we'll be seeing a nuclear Renaissance
now it would be I would be amiss if I
didn't mention
that when you consider all the costs
associated with building of nuclear
power uh
stations
and uh even
um carbon tax you know uh negative
externalities that natural gas is still
a better way of powering civilization
than nuclear it's still cheaper even
when you account for negative
externality of CO2 into into the into
the atmosphere but if people are almost
religiously committed to not using
fossil fuels then nuclear is the way to
go and hopefully in the future Fusion
Marion do you think we're at a point now
as a society where we're you know we
drunk the Kool-Aid a little bit with
Greta thumbberg and you know Extinction
rebellion and saying you know the world
has got 50 harvests left it's 12. sorry
12 or whatever it is I'm being racist
I'm being right exactly that these
people insist upon and
taking school children on exile marches
but now that we've got bills coming and
hitting our map which are just
astronomically High which are going to
mean that a lot of people struggle to
pay their bills do you think this is a
moment where we're all gonna have to
wake up and actually realize what we're
dealing with and how important energy is
I think that we are waking up and I hope
I I think there is a reasonable chance
that we have seen Peak apocalyptic
environmentalism
um I have two reasons to say that one is
that half of the world the
underdeveloped or the developing world
is never going to buy into our nonsense
we just have to stop thinking we just
have to stop thinking and and just don't
don't even pretend that people in India
and China and Bangladesh and Africa
which is which is still very poor are
simply going to start using windmills
it's just never gone it's not going to
happen for decades they would have to be
at a completely different level of
Economic Development to start playing
around with wind farms and whatever so
they're going to be reliant on call and
um
and natural gas for a long long way to
come and even that is better than using
biofuels in order to power their own
societies
uh so that's one half of the population
the second half of the population which
are the advanced economies like yours
and Ours
our economies which are by and large
Democratic and I do not believe that
with any level of brainwashing coming
from Whitehall or from Greta sunburg or
people who glued themselves to roads in
on on M5 or whatever it is uh I don't
think with any level of
of uh of of that kind of propaganda and
brainwashing uh the good people in the
United Kingdom are going to decide that
this is the future they're going to go
in other words democracy is going to win
and if it's not going to be the Tory
party which changes uh the the green
policies and the green New Deal
um or zero Net Zero it's going to be
somebody else and the sooner the British
political establishment
awaits to the fact
that the British people are suffering
and their living standards are
collapsing
the less likely it is that you will have
a really nasty party emerging that will
do it for them and that is that is a
concern that I have that we still have
we still have democracies here in the
West
and if our center right and Center left
simply refuses to acknowledge that lives
of our people are getting worse by
government design
somebody else is going to fill that void
and that it is that void that I want to
avoid
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
well this is a problem because you know
you you see all these politicians and
all these celebrities go on TV and go
look we've got to consume list and yet
they're the ones going on holidays
they're the ones using private jets and
when ordinary people can't afford to
heat their own homes and many of them in
their businesses and pubs are having to
close down or shop for a prolonged
period of time you do think this is
going to create severe civil unrest
because people realize it's not fair
yes and part of the reason why the
public in this country and in yours has
the politicians in utter contempt is
precisely because they see the level of
hypocrisy that is going on in in both
societies I don't have a specifically
strong feeling about guns in this
country which is a very toxic subject
but you always see the politicians being
well protected what other while other
people aren't even though crime is
rising in the United States do you see
them constantly raising taxes on taxes
on air travel but they themselves fly
around on private jets or first class
which is much more carbon intensive you
see them telling you to drive
you know
um little uh prices while they enjoy
being driven around in SUVs as big as a
house
you see them telling you that the world
is going to be swallowed up by by the
oceans while at the same time they're
buying beachfront properties and they
basically think that we are so stupid
and they think that can they can
basically freak us out to an extent
where where any kind of policy can be
can be implemented and to that extent I
was actually impressed with some of the
work done in the UK by your former head
of your Supreme Court Jonathan
assumption who was deeply concerned that
that the kind of public reaction to
covet
uh you know you end up with a Chinese
virus but also with a Chinese Society
where if people get if people can be
freaked out to sufficient extent that
the world is going to implode that they
would be willing to part with their
civil liberties and their basic freedoms
on the other hand
all of these apocalyptic predictions
have been wrong in the past and if you
put a date on it if you say that we only
have five or ten years you know on the
planet left and that that time expires
you know once again we will have to have
a conversation about whether we should
be believing these people you know what
sort of credibility do they have and do
they also realize just how
extraordinarily it is the damaging to to
our institutions
um you know how are we supposed to
believe the leadership in our societies
when they get these calls wrong time and
time again you know they they complain
about populism they are the causes of
populism because they keep on saying
things which are obviously not true
that's absolutely right and and that's
we've seen that right the way through
you know for sincerely Iraq war really
I'm Constantine wrote a brilliant thread
on it which went viral on Twitter
because
we don't have faith in our leaders
anymore and when you look at something
like Net Zero which none of us voted for
none of us was only a small fraction of
people wanted your girlfriend did yeah
exactly yeah
we're only a small fraction of us wanted
and the fact it's going to have such
horrendous consequences
means that what is the point in
democracy really when it comes down to
it all right well look America before
you get into that let's let's talk about
the positive side of this no no let's
keep it he wants to drag us down into
the gutter and into the pessimistic
stuff but you actually have a very
positive message and look I I think
Francis and I both agree with everything
you've said about
um the the impact on Democracy of
hypocritical politicians uh the Chinese
virus giving us a Chinese Society I hear
all that but if you don't mind Francis
let's do a bit of the more positive
stuff because you actually have a gray
and very inspiring message I think which
is that we can use the power of
Technology we can use the power of human
Minds uh the the human Ingenuity that is
contained with within human beings to
triumph over these problems and to
overcome many of these issues and you
mentioned earlier that we could talk
about the data around of that and I'd be
really Keen that we get some of that in
so maranto talk to us about why you are
hopeful and optimistic for the future
what you see as the opportunities for
human beings to to transform the world
and and to continue to expand our
understanding of it
I'm I'm rationally optimistic about the
future just just to just to clarify that
so long as we don't have a massive war
caused by politicians so long as we're
able to innovate
without a precautionary principle so
long as we are able to feel freely speak
and publish and research for which you
need of course freedom of speech and so
long as we have the free markets which
can tell us which inventions and
Innovations are valuable and which
inventions and Innovations are not
valuable but with that being said so in
this book uh we are look we have looked
at 18 different data sets with some of
our data sets going back to 1850 and we
looked at hundreds of Commodities
um Goods finished goods Services food
fuel Etc and what we found is that for
every one percent increase in population
we had one percent decrease in the price
of all of these Goods services and and
commodities
and and that tells us that um
human beings on average are more
producers than they are consumers that
tells us that we are able to to really
produce more wealth than we consume
right
um otherwise you would see the opposite
with every one percent increase in
population you would see a decline so
you would see an increase in prices in
Greater scarcity but once again what we
find is the exact opposite prices go
down the more people you have
um I'm going to give you
um just a few things that we found I'm
I'm going to the the the the longest
data set that we have goes back to 1850
and it's for American
um blue-collar workers this is
manufacturing workers okay so what we
found is that uh pork for example fell
in price by 98 which means that the same
amount of time which got you
um one pound of pork in uh 1850 you now
get 63 pounds of pork for the same
amount of work okay for the same amount
of work that bought you a pound of rice
you now get 41 pounds of rice some
amount of work that got you say a pound
of wheat now you get 31 pounds of wheat
we go with corn Rye but we also look at
minerals like nickel or phosphate or
barley coffee copper and everywhere we
find
that prices have been dropping to such
extent that basically whatever you could
get for an hour of work in in in
1850 you can get you can now get a
multiple even though the number of
people in the world has risen from 1
billion people in 1800 to 8 billion
people today and I should mention that
when we looked at prices what we did we
looked at prices of things relative to
wages because of course wages increase
over time as well as Humanity becomes
more productive and if you let me I'm
also going to give you a Global
Perspective we did it for the United
Kingdom as well but we did a Global
Perspective where we looked at what
happened to prices of Commodities during
the era of globalization which was to
say after 1980 and that's just a period
of 40 years and what we found for
example that coffee fell in price by 90
so now you get
um sorry not now this is where the age
is coming in and I think my glasses not
everything improves over time my friend
no I certainly don't but okay 85 cheaper
you can now get seven for the price of
one pork 84 cheaper you get seven for
the price of one some on 80 cheaper you
can get five for the price of one
and this is just in the scope of the
last 40 years and people might want to
ask you know we we often get you know
part of the Doom and Gloom is that
people feel that things are not
improving at a faster Pace but actually
what we found is that in the last 40
years living standards have improved uh
by about uh by about 250 percent or as a
global average and what people have to
keep in mind when they are thinking is
this fast enough or not is that for tens
of thousands of years human stands of
living haven't changed at all in other
words if if you were living to the age
of 25 or 30 in ancient Egypt you are
living to the age of 25 or 30 in ancient
Rome and then then in Norman England
right
um as many babies died to the Asian
Egyptians as they did uh in in Britain
um in in year 1000 maybe with little
with little differences but but
generally living standards just remained
the same the same amount of food that
you consumed
you were able to consume living on the
age of starvation your parents your
grandparents their grandparents going
back thousands of years you know would
be able to do so the fact that in the
last 40 years alone
we were able to increase our living
standards globally by 250 percent that
in itself should tell you that we are
doing something right
to ignore these you know statistics
because
when you see something like the energy
bills you forget in many ways how good
we have it and actually how rapid
technological progress has been just in
just in the last 10 years if you think
how much everything has changed with the
internet and how much the internet has
been able to change our lives and
improve lives and like for instance this
wouldn't happen so well tell us
something positive to do with technology
as well how can technology and
technological advances improve our lives
in the coming years
well first of all let me acknowledge
that the West is going through and the
whole world actually is going through a
very difficult period
um you know when the the last two years
the last three years I'm trying to be
positive Marion yeah it doesn't come
naturally to him
the last two years have been difficult
and of course that the the sort of slope
of human progress is not a smooth line
upwards it's a jagged line you know
often we take two step forwards and one
step back uh I believe that both our
reaction to covet but also our economic
policies have been you know not not not
everything we have done was right in
fact I think in most of it was done was
done poorly but
um
but I still think that
um very few britons
would would deny that life in 2022 is
better than what it was in 1979 or 1980.
um you know be it be the trip to a
dentist or a trip to a uh to to a doctor
to have a quadruple heart you know
bypass surgery or cars or food or or
even the cleanliness of the environment
I mean Britain is a much much cleaner
country than it was you know 40 years
ago so that being said where would I
take technology I mean I think that
there are tremendous opportunities for
technological uh Improvement of human
society in the future uh biotech
creation of bespoke
Medical Treatments uh for for every
individual
um you know when when the when the
genome was decoded it cost a billion
dollars
now you can get your genome decoded for
a hundred dollars that obviously makes
it easier to identify your risks to give
you a risk profile what you should be
doing with your life how much you should
be drinking should you be smoking should
you be eating certain types of foods
that so that you can optimize your
health in the future
um so I think you know that combined
with
mRNA and the way that mRNA can can be
used not only against covet but they can
be used against cancer against all sorts
of other things artificial intelligence
and human and super Computing can be
applied in order to
really develop new drugs
um discover the
formation of proteins and all other
things and all sorts of other things
that we need in order to produce much
better drugs in order to Keep Us Alive
and healthy for a longer period of time
and obviously a longevity and health are
the best proxies for high standard of
living
um you know because because the longer
we live and the healthier we are that
tells us that we are doing all sorts of
other things in life well what are the
others you know technological I mean I
already talked about biotech
artificial intelligence if it happens it
could really boost our productivity so
even if we do have the world sort of
flatlining in terms of population that
doesn't mean that we wouldn't get any
inventions because human brain would now
cooperate with AI but we just don't know
um whether that's going to happen or
when but but if if we can pull it off
then I think that we can just
dramatically increase the human brain's
computing power hour
um other things that we can talk about
are maybe breakthroughs in energy you
know energy goes into everything as
Europeans and Americans are finding out
right now energy is absolutely
fundamental to powering our civilization
not just this Zoom call
um but also uh the cost of your avocados
or a loaf of bread everything is based
on energy what if we could actually
spend some serious money behind Fusion
Energy which is very safe and could
power our civilization form for
Millennia to come and make energy too
cheap to measure uh what if energy
became free I think that would make our
living standard jump quickly by order of
magnitude and make us much more
optimistic we could cut the price of
absolutely everything we do in society
by significant margin
Marion and uh we've got to wrap up in a
second but uh before we like your last
question I wanted to ask you something
else because uh temperamentally I agree
with you and the more I look at the
facts of it the more I agree with you
and and probably because I grew up in in
the 90s when we had this brief moment of
optimism uh I I am someone who's
inclined to believe that technology uh
and scientific progress is how we are
going to deal with many of the difficult
problems that we do face however we've
also seen as you and Francis were
talking about earlier that when you get
rapid technological change including of
the type that we've seen in in the last
decade particularly
it comes with very significant
trade-offs and the ability to
communicate with everybody in the world
the ability to connect not everybody but
most people in the world through through
the internet has been incredible and
it's also got to the point where you
know countries are having Civil Wars
because of Facebook quite unquote I mean
I'm simplifying but you know what I mean
we are very divided in Western countries
and so on so while remaining optimistic
how do we manage some of the trade-offs
of these technological developments
because it seems to me you know there
that Francis and I are in uh you know
social communication cultural program
and entertainment and particularly
social media that is an area where
everyone knows there's a big problem and
no one quite knows what to do about it
um any technology developed by the human
brain is can be
can be used for good and evil uh a
baseball bat can be used to hit a
baseball and it can be used to to bash
you to death uh not to mention uh guns
and um anything else knives
um
so so what you do with your Technologies
also matter I think that
um
ah any new technology from gramophones
to bicycles was first met with a wall of
negativism in other words writing of
novels was supposed to lead to mental
collapse throughout the Western World
you know the television radio all of
these things were considered to be
potentially
world-ending events uh but they didn't
happen we are I think that when it comes
to social media I don't like them I
don't partake I left Facebook in 2012
when I realized that it was making me
unhappy that what I was putting up on
Facebook was a curated picture of my
life and what I was consuming was a
curated picture of my life so basically
I was posting lies in consuming lies and
once I realized that I left Facebook and
that was a choice a choice which can be
made independently by any number of You
by all 8 billion people so I think that
what we are going through right now is a
period of adjustment to a new technology
but that period of adjustment will will
resolve itself you know it took us 50
years to figure out that drinking and
driving was not a good idea and right
now it's sort of been internalized into
us that cars are much better operated
when you are sober right but it took
time to to to to to square the human
brain with this new technology and I
think that will probably happen with
social media as well or at least I hope
that will happen with social media is
that people are simply going to leave
realize that much of it is simply unreal
that is making them unhappy and they
could be spending their time doing
better things than than being on social
media so
so I think it's it's an these are early
days it's a new technology but I think
we'll probably figure it out in the way
that we have figured it out with novels
and bicycles and radio and television
Marion it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for coming on uh we're
gonna finish with the our final question
which is always the same it's what's a
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be
well I I I'm I'm basically a follower of
the Enlightenment I I believe that in
Enlightenment I aspire to the ideals of
the Enlightenment and one of the main
features of the Enlightenment was
freedom of speech I don't think that we
are putting enough emphasis on the way
that freedom of speech is being
destroyed by our governments by the
media by cancer culture freedom of
speech is not only necessary in order to
produce new inventions and Innovations
but also to produce new ideas
um in this country though we need a lot
of reforms because the country is not
functioning very well and I wouldn't
like
ideas that I propose to be canceled just
because they seem to outrageous in the
same way in the United Kingdom you need
to undertake a lot of reforms and what
if somebody tells you that your proposal
for
I don't know NHS reform is somehow
I don't know
um whatever they will cancel you for
that so we need freedom of speech we
need to preserve freedom of speech it's
absolutely fundamental we should be
talking about it more we should be
talking more about people getting
canceled for joking uh for expressing
wrong ideas and also for having
um peculiar forms of behavior and that's
important because as we discuss in our
book a lot of people on whom we rely for
some of the most important Innovations
and inventions in the world are also
very peculiar people right
um look at somebody like Steve Jobs
incredibly difficult and apparently
quite an unpleasant person to be about
but he's changed the world
um look at the personal peccadillos of
of somebody like um
uh like um like Bill Gates
um again an imperfect man who has
changed the world look at somebody like
the core discoverer of DNA Jim Watson he
likes to provoke people he likes to
constantly needle them with Politically
Incorrect opinions but what if we shut
him down just because he was Politically
Incorrect would we have had DNA
and so I think that Federal speech but
also I think greater tolerance for
eccentricity
for neurodivergent individuals who may
be seeing that saying the right things
and have weird uh forms of behavior but
we need them because genius usually is
come comes with people on the Spectrum
a fantastic answer Marion I really
recommend everybody gets super abundance
uh tell uh our fans uh where they can
find your work online
thank you very much so the book uh is
super abundance we have a website
www.superabundance.com
the other website which I run is human
progress.org and if you are interested
in getting in touch I can be found at
cato.org
thank you very much we're going to ask
you a couple of questions that only our
supporters will see in a moment but for
now thank you so much for joining us and
thank you for watching and listening
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one oral
show all of them go out at 7pm UK time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we have made so much progress and we're
about to throw it all away because of
the narratives that we've discussed and
we explored in the interview what are
the best strategies to ensure that we
don't do that and we pull back from The
Cliff face
[Music]